hey guys dr. Burke here I want to talk
about organic seat count so the cool
thing about this it is certified organic
so that's good it's from Iceland so it's
probably the last place on the planet
that's clean so that's good there's no
toxicity in the ocean but this this
sessi kelp is basically like a it's a
vegetable from the sea so it has all
these trace minerals and as all these
nutrients but with the main one being
the iodine in the right source to
support the thyroid this is really
really important and the female
reproductive system especially if they
get fibrocystic breasts or and I'm not
saying this cures cancer I'm just saying
this that if you look up iodine and
organic sea kelp a lot of times
deficiency of this can lead to
triggering the risk of cancer and I'm
not saying this is going to cure you but
just look there's a link between the two
but anything reproductive wise female
this is a really important one that tank
and the problem is these these minerals
are not in on land base it's only
actually in the sea so this is a really
good thing to take and I recommend
taking if you're trying to solve like a
pro if you have an issue just take three
in the morning if you're not having an
issue you're like on a maintenance take
one in the morning that's all you need
don't take it right before bed because
it might increase energy but it's really
good for thyroid health as well alright
so that's pretty much the gist of that
the only time you would not take this is
if you have a hyper thyroid you're hyper
your thyroids going too much because
then this will basically speed it up
more and then the other thing is if
you're allergic to iodine you wouldn't
want to take it okay hope this helps
I'll see you the next video